[Musik]
hallo mein name ist sogar letztlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video hier geht es um titel eingeblendet
us oder du spielst und ja das ist das
spiel was wir heute machen wir machen
kein spiel wir spielen ein spiel nicht
dumm und kann nicht sprechen
wir haben einmal story endlich würde
sagen wir kriegen einfach mal auf story
wenigen komisch schönen hund faruck
abgezogen
schaut mich um eine ziege die tanztag
also 21 und ich muss sie kostet das für
eine scheinsicherheit steht hier ein
[Musik]
durchdringender do nothing
endlich habe ich mal was geschafft hier
die table kommt als nächstes ich weiß
nicht wie das gehen soll also ich glaube
ich drücke aber so
[Musik]
hab ich wieder geschafft was stecke
deinen ort als nächste woche so jetzt
wir wie also einige das auge
[Musik]
was das denn für ein hektisches spiel
ich habe das gefühl dieses spiel kann
man es nur ungeschnitten kommentieren
weil so wirklich mitschneiden ich werde
daher gekommen die ganze zeit neue
aufgaben binnen kürzester sekunden jahr
werden eine dampflok die spaghetti essen
einen vogel sieht die ost agenten und
fährt den vogel hinterher
die ausgangssituation chuck ist das erbe
also doch also den haben wir getötet der
arge hoch hier die iss lebt als die
aufgaben wiederholen sich prächtig
weiter in ihrer jetzt bin wahrscheinlich
wenn essen ist die nächste aufgabe und
war hier ein und nahm noch in dem ich
werde immer besser wieder nicht nur
meine damen und herren das heißt ich
stelle mich erzählen jetzt auch gab es
mit table hatten sie auch schon
aussteller erwartet wird dass die ganz
oben mit holz nach oben hauen ufo mit
kaputten wir haben als die sofort die
aufgaben hier wiederholen sich
tatsächlich von wenig also ich packe ihn
hier vorne drauf
bürgerschaftlich engagiert wieder
wechselt also diesmal wir den drachen
abschließend ich hoffe ich fit bin
[Musik]
warum jetzt soll ich die show gewinnen
ich weiß nicht ich bin so klug
red back also marie fliege kaputt
[Musik]
also ich soll dafür sorgen dass der
dumme sparen
[Musik]
ich habe neue spieler ich glaube ich
weiß mittlerweile wie das spiel
funktioniert und war dadurch desto
weiter man kommt in den bisherigen
sachen und desto mehr man davon
hinkriegt und die sachen wiederholen
sich auch immer krieg wenn dadurch mehr
hin und wenn man das hat sich bei neue
spiele also wir haben wir spielen noch
ein durchlauf hier haben einen roboter
zu befreien
ich weiß nicht was machen ok ich
attackiert wieder da seid ich musste
wieder den typen boxen kabinett komplett
zerstört begleitet neben aufgabe das
habe ich getan noch keiner hingekriegt
die wahl funktioniert wieder essen das
heißt einfach nur im passenden
augenblick so hier drauf gründen davon
wie klappt auf jeden fall
wenn hier jetzt wieder den tisch um
stoßen deshalb versucht ihn wieder bis
zum move oder oben hin zu hauen genauer
geklappt jetzt wieder den verstecken
die aufgaben die ganze zeit wiederholen
da steht hier vorne auf der ecke haupt
seinen ford raus ich habe wieder
gewonnen die nächste aufgabe ist hier
die eier also wieder das auge säubern
als nächstes ich weiß nicht was das
jetzt die tabletten genommen das war
nicht ganz wurde ja dass sie wieder mehr
wertschätzung auch hingekriegt also das
mit der fliege hörte da haben wir die
spinne mit den robotern arsch
schon wieder neue games am start das
ganze game bestätigt daraus ist man die
gleichen aufgaben machte dann kommen
immer wieder neue games dazu
das war vom wieder meine damen und
herren ich wollte heute eigentlich mit
länger machen und ich mein gerät schon
ich habe auch noch schon wieder ein paar
neue spiele auf freigeschaltet hier wenn
ihr wollt ich das game noch mal viele
ich habe jetzt noch viel mehr eine
mini-em freigeschaltet hat man leider
nur zum enden weil ich nach amerika
afrika und noch überhaupt nicht gepackt
habe und mir nicht zu viel zeit lassen
darf hier findet ihr oben zwei die
eingeblendet bla bla bla bla bla dann
welche neuer abonnent von meinem canale
kostenlos kuhlmann wird ein besserer
mensch stattfindet die ebenfalls meinen
shop gibt das blabla eingeblendet 400
ein anderes video klick darauf die stars
bla bla bla bla
warum hat er abgesagt